preparations for neighed are underway
along the Gulf Coast a state of
emergency has been declared for 29
counties in Florida as well as in
Alabama Louisiana Mississippi and New
Orleans those areas are home to almost
12 million people a mandatory curfew
goes into effect in New Orleans tonight
at 7 o'clock local time Michelle Miller
is there at Michelle good morning good
morning I'm here along the banks of Lake
Pontchartrain and the waves are kicking
up pretty good here in addition to that
curfew that you mentioned the mayor of
New Orleans has also issued a mandatory
evacuation order for anyone living
outside of the city's flood protection
system we're looking at the wall just to
my left here and we should know that
officials closed some 200 flood gates
overnight ahead of a storm surge that's
expected to be as high as 10 feet water
it's already spilling under streets in
the Venetian Isles neighborhood of New
Orleans it's an unusually high tide
residents here have until noon today to
leave that's when the neighborhood comes
under a mandatory evacuation order can't
call anybody not coming you know but so
it is a good idea to leave from those
people
others have already left their homes the
first of a qyz began arriving at this
shelter in Plaquemines Parish about 20
were here by late Friday night with more
expected to come they very good care
with us one is opening centers so we can
have a place to go
and I appreciate it while lines at the
gas pumps formed on Friday many in New
Orleans had their minds on the city's
water pumps nearly 10 percent of them
are off line but Mayor Mitch Landrieu
says the city is ready
can you guarantee the people of New
Orleans that pumping system will work as
it should as a matter of fact I can we
have plenty enough power and plenty
enough pumping capacity to handle those
potential rain events 20-year New
Orleans resident Cathy Adams spent the
day packing sandbags she's hoping
they'll keep the water out of her
property but it may worsens she won't be
there to see what happened so when you
heard about Nate what went through your
head stop packing said I want another
Katrina if you look at my car I'm packed
ready to go packed ready to go closes in
a core in some cases rain was one
concern but really folks west of that
eye wall are concerned about wind and
with wind comes power outages so folks
here in New Orleans are urging residents
to have supplies and to stockpile them
that will keep them in supply for at
least a week Anthony all right Michelle
Miller in New Orleans thanks Michelle